if you're a fan of Hunter hunter them
for the love of marijuana please
subscribe to this channel for regular
updates straight to your YouTube feed
these humans are definitely foolish
creatures think as hard as those weak
brain cells of yours can manage and tell
me do you humans ever listen to the
cries of Mercy coming from the pigs and
cows that you slaughter they didn't
think so
hello and welcome to Hunter hunter 101
the series that breaks down everyone and
everything in the Hunter hunter world
and today it's time to examine a race of
creatures that came close to bringing
the entirety of humanity to the brink of
extinction with the chimera ants chimera
answer a breed of creature in the hunt
hunt world well known to the Brom of
humanity however they also have much
larger cousins that exist on the
landmass known as the dark continent and
these giant ants are going to be the
ones that we primarily focus on here
today chimera ants generally take many
traits from real-life ants but with one
exceptionally important difference which
would go on to redefine them as a
species and that is their Queens method
of reproduction being Fat Joe Genesis
and this is essentially a process
whereby an organism consumes food in
order to produce offspring rather than a
more standard method of breeding as a
result the genetic information imparted
onto the offspring comes directly from
the food source so that might not sound
so great to us because if we say it's
spaghetti bolognaise and then give birth
to a tomato humanity probably yeah well
it wouldn't be in a good place however
to a species that could wield it
effectively it can lead to evolution on
a scale of world domination
I should also probably note that despite
the legit scientific sounding name that
is Fat Joe Genesis this does not
actually exist in the real world just in
case any of you were wondering but as
fate would have it to chimera and queen
would find her away from the Dark
Continent to the human realm contained
within Lake Mobius and so as was a
natural biological drive she immediately
said about spawning a colony and this
queen would go in to feed on many of the
human realms familiar animals as well as
eventually a large quantity of humans
themselves and I want to say right here
and now that feeding on humans would not
only lead to the greatest strengths of
the Chimera ant colony but also to its
greatest detriment oh and it's also
incredibly important flag that these
ants would by-and-large also figure out
how to wield the complexities of men as
a result of human consumption which as
you'll go on to see is downright
terrifying however with this in mind the
Queen's colony was built up rather
rapidly without much notice from the
outside world due to the Queen having
ended up on the shores of NGO the neo
green life Autonomous Region a part of
the world that has made a conscious
decision to reject modern tech
oh gee and live a simple life and to
such the humans living in ngl made for
some very easy initial food for the
colony speaking of a chimera ant colony
consists of a military s can of command
and it all commences right at the top
with a queen without a queen there is no
colony it's that simple
so most colonies do style their lives
with but a single queen who hunts for
food on her own until she has birthed
enough soldiers to procure food for her
the queen also has the responsibility of
selecting a location to serve as a nest
in which she will spend the large
majority of her life constantly
consuming resources in order to
eventually give birth to a king and we
will get back to the king in a second
but as you may have noticed there are a
couple of other stages between the Queen
and the soldiers this is due to the fact
that as the Queen gains more and more
food provided by said soldiers she can
begin to make stronger tiers of ants
with the immediate upper level being
that of the officers and here we start
to see some familiar faces with some
officers of marijuana colony including
the other angry Ramat the ever brilliant
acog oh and the other uncreative lee
named koala who is an ant based on yes
you guessed it a koala I mean at the
very least it is nice to see some
Australian representation in Hunter
hunter above the offices we have a tier
of even greater Authority known as
squadron leaders who each report
directly to the Queen herself each
squadron leader has command of roughly 4
to 5 individual officers who in turn
lead 10 to 15 soldiers known as peons
but squadron leaders make up the large
majority of chimera ansel we are
familiar with with some well-known ones
being Chi to marry our own cult well
Finn they all and the list goes on and
on but above this is where the serious
power begins because in preparation for
birthing the king the Queen creates a
Royal Guard tier consisting of a handful
of exceptionally powerful ants whose
primary objective is to rear the king
into the world and to lead the colony
with him or to leave the nest and mate
to produce the next queen in the case of
marijuana colony 3 Royal Guards were
produced being NetHope tow Shia poof and
mint with AUP and it should also be
noted that the Queen was responsible for
naming all of the Royal Guard and so I
will forward all of my complaints
directly to her when it comes to
pronouncing the names of these
individuals but for now I really do need
to hammer home the point that even
though the Royal Guard are only one tier
removed from squadron leaders these
three figures are on an infinitely
greater scale of power especially in
regards to nen each of the Royal Guard
were born with ungodly quantities of
aura with knuckle estimating that ups or
reserve exceeded that of 700 thousand
units which for some perspective is ten
times the amount wielded by hunter
extraordinaire morale
and it can be assumed that the other
royal guards share a similar quantity
and in addition to being born as natural
geniuses in regards to nen the Royal
Guard are also effectively superhumans
with unfathomable strength speed and
intellect making them nigh on impossible
opponents to defeat and the perfect
protection for the King not that I guess
the King really needs it in this case
and that of course brings us to the king
who in the case of this giant ant colony
was Marilyn and he was born into this
world with power far greater than any
other being we've ever seen in the
series excluding nanika of course but
Mara well naturally bilities including
that of men make the Royal Guards look
like a speck of sand on a desert planet
but what would these ants go on to do
with the largest mass of power we've
ever seen in the series well after being
born the king and his royal guards
abandon the colony headed to the
Republic of East corto and immediately
commandeered a palace held by the
Republic's dictator from here the plan
was to initiate what was referred to as
a sorting whereby the nearly 5 million
citizens of each quarter would be
transformed into human and hybrid
soldiers capable of wielding men
although it was estimated that only 1%
of the population would have the
strength to survive the sorting process
in theory resulting in an army of
roughly 50,000 hybrids which is still an
awful lot of men wielding ants and an
army easily capable of conquering the
world speaking of conquering the world
was the next plan phase and it was
referred to as unification
although exactly how this would go about
would change over the course of the
Chimeran talk mostly due to mara wants
ever-changing views on humanity but with
Mara Webb and the Royal Guards on their
new life's mission this left the rest of
the colony spawned by the Queen and a
bit of a loss the main issue is that the
Chimera and Queen had passed away whilst
giving birth to Mero M and most of the
individuals in leadership positions felt
distinctly separate from Mero em and the
Royal Guard as species and so the
remainder of the squadron leaders and
their forces splintered off into the
world of course some of them would
continue to serve marijuana but many
squadron leaders went off and did their
own thing such as cult forming a truce
with humans with the intent to stop Mero
M horses on creating a nest in meteor
city only to be dispatched by the
Phantom troop but here's the thing
though the very fact that ants were
having thoughts like this is very unlike
and in many ways counterintuitive to
what a Chimera ant should be feeling and
that was due to the influence of
humanity within their DNA human
incorporation had brought with it a vast
quantity of feelings ideas and ambition
and it was not secluded to the
lower-level life-forms either as even
the Royal Guard each had their own
personal struggles of inner turmoil to
deal with over the
course of the Chimera ant arc and Mara
web in particular would also have an
existence changing influence from the
realm of humans although not so much in
the form of his food but in a character
by the name of Kaimuki who despite being
blind was an undefeatable gungi player
who pushed marihuana thinking and
planted the seeds of his respect for
humanity
although humankind would not simply sit
and wait for their eventual demise as by
now the hunter Association were well
aware of the apocalyptic level danger
presented by the chimera ants and an
extermination team was formed led by the
chairman of the Association
Isaac Metro this team didn't simply
purely consist of humans either but also
some chimera ants who had defected being
a cargo of male urine and the newly
crafted ant hybrid of pom Siberia and
the crux of this plan was the
extermination team splitting off into
smaller groups separating the King from
his Royal Guard and should all go well
killing them all and saving humanity
cause it didn't exactly go to plan
though in fact there were only really
two parts of the plan that did with one
being when nephew Peter was killed by
gone and the other with Metro versus
marijuana and although it did cost him
his life nattara was eventually able to
cause marrow and death and in the
process the deaths of yupi and Shia poof
as well with all three eventually
falling victim to the secondary effects
of an explosive known as the poor man's
rose with that said not all chimera ants
were killed and many of them do still
remain in existence today having been
integrated into society and labeled as
magical beasts also while the sorting of
the people of east quarter did not go as
planned
the king and his Royal Guard did manage
to forge themselves 5000 chimera and
hybrids the cocoons of which were
acquired by the vice-chairman of the
hunter Association parastone hill and
all of whom have likely hatched by this
time in the story and it would seem that
he now wilts his own personal army of
ant human hybrids some all fun facts
about chimera ants in this world chimera
ants also go by a second name which is
gourmet ants
this name spawns from the fact that ants
on notoriously picky about their food
consumption choices and this can be seen
reflected in marijuana colony where a
large number of ants developed a taste
for gourmet humanity
aka nen uses interestingly enough
chimera ants who were crafted from human
DNA seemed to be capable of recollecting
memories from their previous human
existence leading some of them to even
consider themselves as the same person
reborn and while nothing is being
confirmed in regards to this a thought
has been floated that this may be
because of the human soul surviving past
the fagio Genesis process should net
arose original extermination plan have
failed there was allegedly a plan B that
was on Stan
I'm ready to go although in the end it
was unnecessary due to both Miriam's
change of heart and his inevitable death
from the poor man's rose and finally a
truly useless fact in marijuana colony
at one stage there existed a total of 36
squadron leaders however in the series
only 31 of them were ever named and that
pretty much does it for the chimera ants
if you enjoyed this video and the
content this channel produced in general
then please do consider donating to the
new world revue patreon because the
support of all of your amazing people is
what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style then please do leave this video a
like share or subscribe because it also
helps support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please to head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan takes place on a daily basis
and finally please do comment with who
what or where you'd like to see featured
on the next Hunter hunter 101
[Music]
we'll the anime of Hunter hunter ever
come back to be honest unless they
decide to reanimate everything we've
already done I kind of doubt it the
problem is that the manga hasn't even
completed a single arc since the anime
left off not technically anyway I mean
you can split the Dark Continent
preparation and the succession more up
but it's kind of pointless and I think
the best possible thing you could do is
perhaps make an OVA focusing on the
Hisoka and krola fight in Heaven's arena
that could be a lot of fun and maybe you
could pepper in some Dark Continent
stuff to fill it out announcement rege
but really there is very little to
animate sadly you ever thought about
doing a video on berserk yes I
definitely have it would be very heavily
opinion based though because I don't
have the same kind of grasp on berserk
as I do with Hunter hunter or one piece
so it would be very much in I like this
because of this sort of video but I
think it's a pretty inevitable topic if
this channel does keep up the general
anime and manga direction although
that's a pretty big if what kind of
anime / manga inspired tattoo would you
get so I've thought about this quite a
bit and it would definitely be the team
die-cutting symbol from Gurren Lagann
the problem is I just don't know where I
would showcase such a glorious thing if
you have any ideas on where such tattoo
sugar then please do leave them in the
comments below